If you think dishes in the shower is bad,
did I ever tell you about the time that I pissed in a bucket
for a week when I was nine months pregnant?
And hindsight,
that project might have been a bit of a piss poor decision.
And I know on TikTok, I always have a project with a crazy deadline,
but it's not just on TikTok.
Like these are genuinely and authentically
the types of situations I find myself in across my life.
And I don't know why. Okay,
so it's about six years ago,
I had a six year old and a four year old
and I was heavily pregnant with baby girl.
And I had said to my husband that I wasn't gonna do another baby
in our current bathroom. We didn't have a bathtub.
I really wanted a tub.
I wanted to soak my old lady pregnant bones in the tub.
I wanted to bath with the baby.
I wanted to bath the baby
and I just I wanted a tub.
For context, we had spent the previous two years
like slowly renovating that little house
and it was time to do the bathroom.
And there's nothing like some crazy
nesting hormones to make you tackle an impossible project on your own.
And in typical Britain Mart fashion,
we had a crazy deadline. We had two weeks to get it done.
And that was because those two weeks for the school holidays.
So we thought we could Palm our children off to the grandparents
for at least a good chunk of that time
so that we could do all of the things that we needed to do
to make this bathroom happen before the baby arrived
and because our house at the time was quite little
we only had the one bathroom
but the reality of that was that once the toilet was gone
the toilet was gone
and I don't know how much you know about um pregnant people
but we we pee a lot we don't pee a lot in volume
but we pee a lot in frequency
and I can't believe I'm telling you this
I I put a bucket in a cupboard
and when I would get up in the night and need to pee
I would go and use the bucket and if I needed to go number two's
I would drive to the local gas station look
this is probably information you don't need to know about me
but now you know but anyway
we got the bathroom done before the baby arrived cause you know
babies are notoriously very judgemental about things like bathrooms
and now when I'm doing my dishes in the shower
and I'm not in the shower while I'm doing the dishes
by the way people asking that on my last video
I'm I'm doing them in the shower
but I'm not also having a shower although that would be efficient
but while I'm doing them I'm Reminding myself that at least
I don't have to piss in a fucking bucket.